[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux états unis deux hommes tués par un
train en rendant hommage à leur frère
tué par un train donc voilà c'est pas
des envies dire c'est pas de bol c'est
pas de bol
n'était pas sur la bonne voie pour les
funérailles je pense je suis vraiment
ravi pour vous de vous offrir ces 10000
euros et vous allez en faire quoi si ses
patrons indiscrets
j'ai perdu
donc d'accord ok il
suffit de demander aux idées verront
attention parce qu'il ya le codi
quelle grippe
il ya le verrai ce qu'il démontre que
lille chez les petits
et la gastro qui va arriver premier
confinement tout le monde sérieux pour
aller chercher les denrées nécessaires
mais et parmi ces denrées bon il y as je
suis désolé il ya le papier toilette
voilà donc j'étais parti en catastrophe
parce que nous en manquions à la maison
et j'arrive dans le rayon est
malheureusement plus un seul paquet à
l'aller alors on va faire une série de
celle fille en régime kylie ann embase
zoomer dans les yeux police est
légèrement pour savoir justement si vous
êtes plus photogénique en plissant les
yeux attention qu'il y a allez-y
regardez ce que ça donne à la hausse
bien que vous êtes aux toilettes encore
là mon avis vous avez un peu de force
est alors je vais au bout de l'allée et
là je vois un type qui a un caddie mais
rempli papier cul alors je me dis mais
julie mais monsieur voir des comptes
veulent soyez un peu solidaires a laissé
aux autres et m'a dit monsieur laissez
moi faire mon travail une fois que
j'aurai rempli leur rôle encore
là je devais dire vous avez déjà passé
deux épreuves à l'entrée et les marches
banon alors il ya les images oui bien
sûr qu'on a les images
alors ya débat
brestois
c'est vrai ma ds le râble 2 3 4 et
d'amour tu m'amènes sur toi c'est pas
moi qui viens faut que ce soit vraiment
faut que tu vas fort faut que j'attire
thach thât
[Musique]
cet après midi je pars embattled urgente
schisme avec paga face à 12 et pas et
sinon j'étais assistante dentaire tous
les trucs d'urgent type tu connais par
coeur
j'ai toujours rêvé d'être infirmière
pense que les infirmières elles sont
trop sexy et comment je suis trop sexy
du coup je vais trop fort tu sais tu
mets ton fils je vais mahjoub grecque
c'est super dans les tenues pari tenu
pari
est ce que serait tu peux expliquer la
tenue que tu portes un petit peu alors
je rentre une tunique avec ce qu'on
appelle le scapulaire est comme une
sorte de table il travaille j'ai un
voile sur la tête et n'oubliez pas que
vos j'ai fait est les meilleurs
eric zemmour qui s'y essaient vraie
blague est resté par une grande partie
l'électorat féminin c'est étrange non
c'est fou parce que
se faire traiter d'imbécile et de colas
les femmes les femmes commencent à
sentir qu'il ne les considère pas trop
elle là vous avez un leçon vous avez ce
sixième sens
le sixième sens féminin vous sentez les
choses oh là là la belle mamelle et
adoré ça
voilà et la vache est confiant
je laisse le bourreau ça c'est plus sexy
que cette petite dame et ariadna rang
des moines stéphanie britney spears geri
halliwell
est là bas j'ai lu thi minh alger miley
cyrus et les retraités rita aura bien
c'est lady gaga
est d'ailleurs ce n'était pas une vraie
vache n'ont plus qu'a été tripotées
marre de lire tout à l'heure c'est
christine bravo déguise
[Rires]
christophe dechavanne et christine bravo
3 jours ci vient
cg plaie à la tête après la fin de
l'émission à non je serai sur la
supporte pas il doit avoir la de pas
être la vedette
il ya une déclaration aussi de jean
marie le pen qui vous a interpellé
philippe cette semaine trois relais
d'eric zemmour il a aidé cette phrase
très forte la seule autre personne
envers laquelle j'ai éprouvé un tel élan
de sympathie c'est saddam hussein et oui
parfois
ce
n'est pas deux ans et par un gros boulot
je voulais rajouter un truc usine on
rajoute rien tu as un diamant brut sera
pas mieux un journaliste qui demande
simplement un responsable taliban de
situer son pays dans le monde regardez
l'iphone ou et l'afghanistan
c'est dur à trouver
quelqu'un sait où c'est
aussi ont déjà l'asie
[Musique]
c'est là
à oui c'est là comment s'appelle le
jeune journaliste du parfum de la dame
en noir jean paul gaultier rouletabille
qu'elle est l'initiale du super héros
interprété à la télé par adam west à la
fin des années 60
écoutez moi
c'est
banana split un super héros pourquoi ils
vous ont pas peut-être pour faire partie
du jury miss à savoir et vous christine
wolverine et empêche que pas de pognon
je fais pas de pognon je vais pas la
télévision
au liberia pays où près de la moitié de
la population vit dans l'extrême
pauvreté un jeune homme de 19 ans
livreur à moto a retrouvé un sac
contenant 50 mille dollars alors que ses
amis l'inciter à le garder il l'a rendu
à sa propriétaire
résultat le président georges weah l'a
décoré pour son geste et lui a également
attribué un salaire le financement de
ses études et même deux motos en
dédommagement libre virgules il fonce
dans la moto d'un policier occupés a
interpellé un sdf qui se masturbait
c'est beaucoup d'infos d'un coup donc
je me laisserais pas d'intégrer à ses en
haute-loire donc on peut dire que le
policier a fait d'une pierre deux coups
y on va finir avec avec edouard balladur
on va se finir et qui dort balladur
quand même
avec qui j'ai envie de me finir mais pas
avec cette fois la [ __ ] dure je vous
demande de vous arrêter